how many film submissions did you watch
Total from your running Nifty I think I
probably watched
nearly 10 000 films probably I mean a
lot
um we were getting thousands of
submissions in the first few years I was
watching every single one of them
um eventually we got more people
involved to do especially pre-screening
and kind of start uh
I don't say eliminating but kind of
limiting films but we were always very
fair we had multiple people watch every
film so it wasn't just like one person
deciding on it but yeah I watched a ton
of films while doing the festival and I
think it definitely had an impact on me
because for one I saw a lot of really
bad films of course and so I saw what
not to do and not how to learn from that
and then I saw every once in a while so
I saw some incredible movies that were
just like mods mind blown I was like how
did someone my age make this you know
and so it was it was probably again this
like amazing almost Film School like
experience but in an even more probably
Modern Way of just watching all these
films from all over the world of all
different kinds raw and super
professional and kind of getting on one
hand analyzing them as a viewer and
being like would people like this and
should this be in the festival but also
as a filmmaker being like wow look what
they did or you look what they did and
how we should not do that and so it
probably I'm sure contributed a lot in
terms of expanding my filmmaking you
know knowledge college and abilities
after watching so many films for so many
years
so then what do you think makes a bad
movie what were some of the things where
you could almost tell within the first
maybe 30 seconds
I think it was just
it was not telling an authentic story
you know someone trying to copy
something that they had seen already
like making action spoof on on some
movie they liked
you know or doing something probably the
mistakes we all do which is like trying
to copy something and not having any
sort of original kind of I deal with it
um
and I think to just sometimes trying to
do maybe too much
um because we had plenty of films that
were very simple
made with no money and sometimes those
were some of the best films but then you
had someone who was maybe trying to do
two something too ambitious for what
they the resources they had maybe
um there was always issues with acting
of course you know performances because
you're probably limited on who you can
get
um there was technical challenges but I
honestly don't think a test the
technical ability of a film is always
really the best judge of it I mean you
could have a really
um raw film that doesn't have the most
amazing cinematography or whatever but
if it has a really great story
um it can be super successful so I think
it was always just trying to find those
stories
um that that were captivating and
whether that was a documentary or a
short film or whatever but yeah it was
just kind of trying to find those just
really captivating stories
from your time with Nifty what did you
see with the submissions that you found
really made a film satisfying any genre
I think what makes the film satisfying
is when it makes you feel something and
uh you know whatever that is whether
it's a sad feeling a Happy Feeling being
scared whatever I think that that was
when I knew we had a good film was what
I was you know after watching hundreds
if not thousands of films you kind of
get a little numb sometimes but then you
turn one on while screening them for the
festival and it would just
Captivate you and grab your attention
and make you feel something and if it
can make you feel something after
watching tons of other films and kind of
being bored and over over that then you
know it's probably gonna uh Captivate
everyone else and so that's kind of what
I was always looking for was what are
those just really
compelling films that would make me feel
something whatever that was and I think
that's the same with anything now and
that's what I try to think about when I
make a film too is just you know how can
I make people feel something
um and I think for for me that was
always kind of trying to tap into
emotion because that's just kind of what
I always went to for some people it
might be comedy or something else but I
think if you can if you can do that you
can you can make a great film
what about a non-nifty submission
um what was one that made you feel
something however old you were
as a kid my parents actually would
either take me to a lot of movies or uh
we had a video store near our house and
so we would rent a lot of films and it
was like an independent video store so
it was we'd sometimes find movies that
you know would wouldn't be a blockbuster
or something like that and so I actually
probably had a pretty good
Movie experience as a kid watching
probably a lot of movies that were more
older than I really was like not
necessarily kid movies but like I mean I
remember being pretty young and watching
uh To Kill a Mockingbird and I remember
at first my mom had rented it and you
know she said you have to watch this and
we did but it was like it was in black
and white and for the first few minutes
I was like this is going to be boring
like what is this like you know I was
very young at the at the time but then
within probably the first five minutes I
was totally hooked because it is such a
captivating story right has great
characters and also there was these
young kids in the movie which I was
probably the same ages as them on the
screen and so I think that hooked me and
so I think it's the it's the same idea
where if a movie can grab you and grab
at your emotions or or Captivate you in
some way it's gonna have you and then
obviously from there you still have to
have the rest of the film be compelling
good acting good storytelling otherwise
but
um I think that's just so important is
just to have something what's something
that's going to grab people and pull you
in
any success stories with Nifty that
really stand out like whether it was a
film that just drew you in or maybe a
filmmaker that you were so compelled by
their story their real story definitely
I mean I think
I saw so many amazing films over the
many years I was running the festival
um you know one in particular was it was
this young
female filmmaker from uh
Afghanistan and
uh she had pulled off making this film
um and it was a documentary kind of
about her life and you know this was in
I don't know
late 2010s I guess uh I don't know
obviously this was like wars were going
on all over in that area and it was just
so profound I guess to kind of see this
story from someone your own age from
around the world
um and then she actually came out to the
festival and we got to meet her which
was incredible
um and there was there were so many
other interesting stories like that I
mean there was I think especially the
documentaries at our Festival were so
compelling just because they were so
personal and real and raw and so
you know we had amazing short narrative
films also all the time but the
documentaries were just so special
because they were coming from basically
someone your own age telling some
usually some really profound amazing
story from their life and so those were
always just so compelling and
captivating and we were able to find
films from really all over the world and
all walks of life and uh it was it was
just always exciting really every time
we would get a submission in and see
kind of what this story was and um you
know a lot of our filmmakers have gone
on to to do big things they've a couple
of them made feature films
um one we had a short documentary in the
festival several years back that uh won
the Oscar for best short documentary
that year you know so it's um it's been
kind of this great
um I guess uh you could just call it
like a farm team or whatever I guess for
for finding these filmmakers and helping
them develop themselves
um but of course not every filmmaker
goes on and has a big success story I
mean most of the filmmakers if you
touched with them now like they probably
won't even be still directing you know
like the reality is it's just obviously
very hard and not everyone that makes a
film when they're in their early 20s
ends up becoming a director you know but
a lot of them are working in the
industry somewhere
um or they're just doing something else
in their life that is creative and
they're using their skills probably as a
filmmaker to kind of to kind of tell
still tell stories in some way whether
it's marketing or whatever and so I
think that's the big thing is that no
matter what happens I think a lot of
anyone who can kind of put together a
film and kind of go down that path it's
just such a great experience for for
kind of learning about yourself but also
about how to kind of like tell a story
and Captivate people and I just think
it's a great skill in life that you can
use one way or the other
did you see where filmmakers who were
overseas maybe did you realize I guess
what privilege we have here in terms of
being able to make something you know
withstanding certain laws whereas in
other countries probably much much
different
much more fear yeah for sure I mean
there was definitely films at times
um
we had a few of our filmmakers
especially from the Middle East uh who
would get into our Festival but then uh
they wouldn't even be able to travel
necessarily to the US to attend the
festival sometimes that was because of
their own country other times it was
because you know the U.S wouldn't let
them in and uh it was definitely a time
period too again it was like you know
the internet was was starting to take
off more I mean this was like you know
Facebook and social media was was
existing but it still was like the world
wasn't as close and connected as it is
now and
um it was always so captivating
captivating when we would get to meet
these young filmmakers from around the
world and cure firsthand for them just
their experiences of their everyday life
because it was and that was what was so
special about the festival is you would
literally have everyone from a very
privileged probably wealthy family to
someone who's poor and we had to
basically raise money to bring them out
to the festival and we did that in some
cases you know and so so but we all were
the same in the end of the day because
we're all filmmakers just trying to tell
stories and it was such a special thing
to kind of see see everyone from all
walks of life interacting and and
getting to kind of share and learn from
each other you know and
um
I think yeah more than anything I think
most young people will understand this
because it's in general uh they're more
exposed to people probably from around
the world but I think you kind of start
to it just makes you realize how similar
everyone is you know and how uh most of
the conflicts and problems uh would
probably be solved if we were all just
like hanging out with each other a lot
more but making movies yeah exactly